i'm a veteran i serve for this country
and you're going to tell me
that my family can't come over from the
middle east to visit me
you're going to ban them because they're
muslim
hi i'm staff sergeant alim shabazz this
is lieutenant commander
mahmoud ahmad hello i'm specialist
sharif i'm pfc
shacker from kuwait specialist husseini
from 182 fa
dragon battalion protecting our great
country
people seeing us as traitors and not
believe that we could be loyal to the
united states
many who haven't served who are in
political positions
want to take away our rights as
americans just because we're muslim
we will go die for other people that
aren't americans
to support their rights of freedom but
yet when i come home
political leaders they talk about
following people tapping their phone
calls putting police in you know
muslim majority neighborhoods
for me that's that's crazy and we need
to stop
it or else we i think we've almost lost
our soul
i know what we were able to accomplish
together in the military
if our own men and women and our armed
forces that are there fighting on a
daily basis
are able to look past the divide based
on
race and religion why can't we who
aren't fighting every day of our lives
do the same thing
you